I went to a normal public school in
Atlanta for my ninth grade year what was
that like
my friends were going to this performing
arts high school it was called
Pebblebrook High School it's one of the
best like public performing arts high
schools in the country and within like
two months I knew it was not for me
what'd you dislike about it I did not
like that my time was dictated by
somebody else basically because I'd been
homeschooled for so long I could get all
of this work done in a two-hour span and
then I would go home and because I
didn't feel academically and challenged
I went to my counselor and I said can I
do online AP classes you were
homeschooled for so long go for two
months I would just say let's go back to
homeschooling what kept you there
because I made a commitment and I wanted
to see it through yeah